[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now if you're
hosting for the holidays paul's on with
taylormade productions the sponsors of
this next segment are giving you tips on
making entertaining easy smart and final
you'll see what i did there check it out
it is now that time to talk thanksgiving
uh-huh so i know you have some good tips
to make things easy for us during the
holidays as we host our small gatherings
right
absolutely so smart and final has you
covered for all things holiday and
they're celebrating their 150th
anniversary but what i'm celebrating is
the fact that they have such great
prices and they have the big club sizes
but without any club membership fee
which we love and it saves you money
versus a regular grocery store which we
love this time of year don't you think
absolutely so what is our first item if
you want to show off
so first up you need a holiday cocktail
and smart and finalize everything you
need for holiday cocktails so what i
have right here is i picked up some
absolute vodka again the club size 1.75
that'll last you a weekend you know and
then i got some kahlua for an espresso
martini because the espresso martini is
back and smart final has premium spirits
and wines like kenwood vineyards from
sonoma my favorite and you might be
saying why are there produce there
because smart final has so many great
produce organic everything like that
so i'm gonna do a bloody mary mix to use
some more of this absolute vodka with
all the produce the next day for
thanksgiving morning
great idea i love that idea
nice and sexy for the holidays too
exactly exactly so moving on from the
drinks to food because you know we're
all looking forward to that thanksgiving
plate
yes absolutely let's start with
thanksgiving breakfast so smart and
final has everything you need with their
first street classic roast coffee they
have some delicious almonds they have a
ton of different different trail mixes
and what i've done is i did an apple
spice parfait here so it's some greek
yogurt which they also have apples and
some of the almonds and i have some
mason jars and smart final has mason
jars and a lot of restaurants shop at
smart and finals so they have everything
you need if you're going to do a
thanksgiving buffet like those chafing
dishes those aluminum oil pans that are
disposable they have metal pans smart
final also has peanut oil that's one of
their top sellers because if you are
deep frying that turkey you need some
smart and finals uh peanut oil to deep
fry it
what don't they have
they have everything you need which
leads me to my next tip which is you
know thanksgiving dinner happens the day
after we want to do something with the
leftover turkey so what are we going to
do we are going to do a better for you
chili with some of the sun harvest
products from smart finals so sun
harvest is their earth friendly their
organic lime they have organic spices we
have you know beans for life right here
we have some of their organic sun
harvest brown and wild rice and then
also smart final has a ton of fresh and
frozen vegetables so we have some pepper
strips right here which are perfect to
work their way in and then also we have
some of the sun harvest dish soap again
it's earth friendly we're trying to be
better for mother nature and the other
thing about smart and fun you can go to
smartandfinal.com and they can deliver
this all to you so you can sit watch tv
have a bloody mary and have smart and
final bring you all of your turkey day
needs this year
thank you to taylormade production